ci avete mai pensato nascere
e il primo grande rischio che ci
assumiamo nella nostra vita
la nascita come parola stessa radice
etimologica di agire e quindi è l'azione
che dovrebbe caratterizzare la nostra
esistenza che non è e non potrà mai
essere lineare qual è l'elemento che
rende unico e speciale la nostra
esistenza
l'imprevedibilità e l'imprevedibilità e
i rischi sono ancora maggiori se dopo
nove mesi nasce un bambino che pesa
esattamente la metà degli altri bimbi
cosa rende speciale la nostra vita ci
avete mai pensato
il fatto che non esistono regole scritte
uguali per tutti eppure tutta la nostra
esistenza
noi la passiamo a pianificare le nostre
giornate di lavoro a programmare le
nostre settimane a organizzare le nostre
aziende in modo maniacale a elevare i
muri con la presunta integrità di
lasciare il caos e le minacce fuori
della nostra vita
la forza non è l'antidoto per risolvere
i problemi della nostra vita ma al
contrario per sviluppare la cultura
della resilienza a mio giudizio è
fondamentale anticipare i cambiamenti
della vita e soprattutto saper reagire a
situazioni di crisi che se ci riflettete
sono delle regole che valgono sia per le
persone ma anche per le aziende come ci
ha insegnato daniel cane man che il
primo e unico psicologo pensate a cui è
stato attribuito il premio nobel per
l'economia
le decisione dell'uomo di check
hahnemann non sono affatto razionali
perché sono sempre influenzate dai
pregiudizi che a loro volta origine le
illusioni
l'uomo dice cane ma vive all'interno di
illusioni costanti che lo confortano
l'illusione per esempio deve riparato al
passato
l'illusione ancora maggiore di aver
compreso e controllato il futuro
a mio giudizio invece la sfida che ci
attende ogni giorno per costruire la
resilienza nella nostra vita e per
prepararci al futuro è quella di mettere
insieme strumenti che costruiscano
giorno dopo giorno la nostra reputazione
sulla nostra reputazione si basa la
qualità della nostra resilienza pensate
ad esempio a come le aziende hanno
reagito in questi ultimi dieci anni
anche quelle grandi si sono induriti
come le querce hanno sviluppato
strategie manageriali rigide complesse
con un unico obiettivo cane man direbbe
con unica illusione quella di mantenere
il caos in questo caso la crisi
economica fuori dal loro perimetro hanno
fatto se ci riflettete come i francesi
quando realizzare una linea maginot
convinti che la forza sarebbe stato
l'unico antidoto per isolarle dalle
minacce tutto quel muro quel cemento che
contribuirono a costruire la maginot
avevano però dei presupposti sbagliati i
tedeschi non avrebbero mai violato la
neutralità del belgio e dell'olanda
gli aerei avrebbero svolto un ruolo
secondario anche nel caso di un
ulteriore conflitto bellico e quindi
oltre a costruire una solida reputazione
qual è l'elemento che in qualche modo ci
può contraddistinguere nella costruzione
della nostra cultura della resilienza a
mio giudizio è fondamentale
ogni giorno investire nella cultura
della resilienza individuando delle
strade e degli obiettivi chiari da
percorrere per fare questo però dovremmo
essere disposti ogni giorno a
distruggere le abitudini consolidate
e quegli schemi abituali che ci
costringono a vedere quotidianamente il
mondo che cambia una velocità
incredibile sempre allo stesso modo
sempre con gli stessi occhi
noi dovremmo fare come polo neal che
quando fu chiamato nel 1987 alla guida
di alcoa multinazionale americana con la
quale probabilmente ognuno di noi ogni
giorno a che fare perché a scola prepara
il packaging della coca cola e al primo
incontro con il management e gli altri
dirigenti del gruppo paul o'neal non
sceglie di parlare di fatturato di
profitti ma si concentra su altri numeri
gli incidenti sul lavoro riducendo gli
incidenti sul lavoro inducendo gli
infortuni alcoa avrebbe aumentato la
sensazione è il livello di appartenenza
e di identità degli operai all'azienda
avrebbe aumentato la propria reputazione
che pensateci bene
avrebbero protetto prodotto effetti
positivi sul fatturato dell'azienda
al termine dei tredici anni tipo luminar
coa
agli inizi del 2000 il fatturato era
passato da 1,5 miliardi di dollari
pensateci a 23 miliardi di dollari
distruggere gli schemi abituali abituare
le persone a ragionare in modo diverso
nel 1917
ma si è di champs distrugge gli schemi
abituali entro i quali per oltre 70 anni
dopo l'espressionismo le persone
concepivano il rapporto tra l'immagine
l'estetica e l'arte ma 62 samp arriva ad
affermare che qualsiasi oggetto può
essere un'opera d'arte anche un
orinatoio queste due storie sono
emblematiche di come per sviluppare
cultura della scienza sia fondamentale
rompere gli schemi perché rompere gli
schemi e ce lo insegna l'arte è
l'elemento che aiuta l'uomo a entrare
nella zona di rischio che è la zona nel
quale l'uomo agisce qual è quella
professione che in qualche modo ha un
rapporto privilegiato coristico ce ne
sono tante ma una in modo particolare
quella dell'alpinista che è una persona
che pianifica programma organizza in
modo maniacale e certosino la sua
scalata ma sa bene che la cultura della
resilienza viene messa a dura prova
quando c'è un imprevisto perché lì che
lui riesce a sviluppare se ci riesce la
cultura della resilienza ea
salvaguardare la propria incolumità e la
propria vita marco confortola e uno
degli alpinisti internazionali più
importanti in questo momento
marco ha scalato 10 dei 14 ottomila
l'ultimo addirittura lo scorso 20 maggio
in himalaya ma acqua pagato un tributo
altissimo alla sua passione perché
pensateci non ha più le dita dei piedi
però continua a scalare e lo fa sempre
senza l'ausilio dell'ossigeno
la frase che vedete riportata dietro di
me è la frase che campeggia sul sito di
marco e ci ricorda che cosa è la vita
il rapporto tra l'imprevedibilità che
sia bella la montagna quando la
frequentiamo la scaliamo ma può
diventare un nemico un elemento austero
nel momento nel quale ci chiede un
grandissimo sacrificio per sviluppare
cultura della resilienza
dall'altra c'è l'uomo che comunque è una
persona fragile e che è messa a dura
prova quando l'imprevedibilità le chiede
di essere resiliente e immaginate che
cosa significa per ognuno di noi quando
le situazioni di crisi i momenti
imprevisti sono determinati dalle
calamità naturali il 6 aprile 2009 è una
data emblematica per il nostro paese ma
anche per una regione come l'abruzzo per
la città dell'aquila perché l'aquila
viene scossa da un importante terremoto
nel volgere di pochi giorni decine di
migliaia di cittadini aquilani vengono
sfollati sulla costa
alcuni di essi
per provare a rimanere uniti fondano
un'associazione culturale jemo nnanzi
che in dialetto aquilano significa
andiamo avanti in questi nove anni
l'attività di jemo nnanzi senza peraltro
chiedere un contributo di euro pubblico
che si è sviluppata attraverso decine e
decine di eventi ha dimostrato ai propri
concittadini
la strada e gli obiettivi per percorrere
la via della resilienza se in questo
momento a l'aquila sono state di
scoperte le antiche mura del 500 lo si
deve a questa costanza questo impegno
continuo degli damon anzi quelle stesse
mura che sono state adesso adottate
dalle associazioni culturali gli
abbondanti in fondo stanno legittimando
anche la reputazione del nostro paese
dell'italia che ha investito sull'aquila
quasi 20 miliardi di euro sono diventati
così famosi di amon anzi che pensa te li
ha voluti incontrare e conoscere papà
francesco
per tutte queste storie per tutti questi
esempi la resilienza con la reputazione
batte la forza un'ultima cosa però
ricordate il bambino della prima slide
beh quel bambino quando è nato dopo nove
mesi
pesava esattamente la metà degli altri
bambini e per questo è stato molte
settimane l'incubatrice poi è cresciuto
quando a scuola è diventato il capitano
della squadra di calcio e giovanissimi
nella sua città si è laureato è
diventato uomo una bella famiglia è una
persona molto felice ma oggi è davvero
contento contentissimo di aver condiviso
con voi la sua idea di residenza grazie
[Applauso]